recording...
*meme review*
Felix has entered the VOID
nvm he bak
[snickering]
You're gonna-
[continues snickering]
I do these things now, and I know Brad or Sive are just gonna show me-
Make it cool, you're supposed to make it cool. I'm supposed to come up. You're not supposed to show me going down
god dammit
Possessed Théoden Laughing
You have no power here...
Oh, what's that? Oh? I'm wearing a hot new merch culturally-cultural appropriating are we Felix, that's right?
Сука
Блять!
[The USSR Theme plays]
Luckily YouTube doesn't know Russian yet,
So we're fine with this meme.
Check out the merch link in the description, limited time availability.
avai-
:O
ohh...
OH GOD
Oh, Oh, No (Got rid of his metrosexual hair)
Oh Hoh Hoh...
;(
What did he do?
wHaT dId yOu dO fElIx?! dId yOu aSk fOr tHe Z U C C ?!
Yes, that's right everybody! I went to the hairdresser, and I said "Hey man! Hit me up with the Z U C C hair!"
That's how I'm committed to the memes. Okay, I'm not some bullsh- memer
This is serious!
For extra slav, I'm gonna...
Pull up my chain
Look how cool this merch is guys, check out link in the description. If you're a real сука, just do it
*LWIAY REVIEW*
Roll the intro in case we haven't already leave your
*The subreddit anthem plays*
But can a reptilian do this?
It annoys me a little bit the fact that he's just become a reptilian when clearly he's an Android.
Perhaps an Android reptilian.
If Finding Nemo had been scientifically accurate...
Nemo's dad would have switched sexes after Nemo's mom died and mate with his...
..?
:OOO
This got 2000 upvoted on the PewDiePie subreddit, congratulations everyone, you're a bunch of scumbags
You're a bunch of weirdo scumbags, congratulations everyone...
The bad news is that he won't get another Bonus Meme for at least a month
[giggles]
You're welcome everyone I'm still smiling this whole week remembering: "It was a bonus meme this week!"
[giggle]
Why are you so happy?
Well ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
The United States government lecturing Mark Zuckerberg about invading people's privaci-
Don't know if you guys have seen the cringing moments of that, I wish I highlighted them better, but
It's pretty bad. There's a lot of good stuff from that hashtag pay brad
Bonus me twisty affect everybody all memes aside, I I don't think I thank Brad enough. I he's been working with me for
five years
It's been that long goddamn yeah, and he really pulled my channel out of the its cringy
Dark, hole that it was
Spiraling down into so... Everyone hashtag. Thanks Brad
Click here if you want to cry sponsor eagle awwww
Can we just let memes die?
Do we have to keep bringing them up by the way guys I don't know if you heard about this new campaign Kony 2012
It's really important cost that I think if we all just get together and support. We can finally defeat this evil man
Damnit GOD DAMNIT
You know how close I am to starting a patreon just so now how to deal with all this I'm not gonna, okay?
I can't even look at myself
I look so weird who is this guy if the B in LGBT stands for
Bisexual doesn't that mean that there are only two gen...
(he is enlightened)
Hmmmmmmmmm
Alien, Italien
I can confirm. Marzia does this all the time
Who is that?
I feel like I recognize it
It looks like some
weird Jerry Seinfeld hybrid
It's disturbing, okay. I don't want to see it.
*Laff*
But who hunts the bully hunters?
Also, congratulations guys the website is down forever
Well done! (Thanks Pewds :D)
I'm proud of you guys. I'm proud
Aren't bonus memes just normal memes, but with peers yelling bonus mean before them?
*Pewdierage*
Are you f*ckin stupid
That's ridiculous. Are you kidding me? That's the most foul thing I ever heard you know what you're perma banned spicy yams
How do I ban I forget (lol) makes Americans look bad
Well, that's true
Makes British people look bad
Makes lizard people look bad
Oh, there's poor lizard people makes Swedish people look unoriginal
( Pewds gonna cry :(  )
I'll take it you know what fine how to give a manly handshake
Oh like. I don't need to I don't need to know this get out of the my get out of my list
wait so
Do you think Pewds should add bonus news to PewNews? That's... That is ridiculous?
PewNews is a very serious news website. We don't we don't do with memes. Okay. Please don't make me laugh
Master Brad, there are too many memes. What are we going to do?
I kept thinking why are they so many Brad memes?
And then I realized I think I said it in the last video tonight next one
We're gonna have it a little themed around Brad and and Brad to
What is this?
Subscribers hate him he managed to piss off. What is this? I kind of want to click
Hi, everybody. It's me Brad Woto from the PewDiePie channel. You can follow me on Twitch at
twitch.tv/bradwoto
When you're at a zoo and see a lizard. Oh hi mark
Uber driver oops wrong turn. Youtuber: I was almost kidnapped.. Story time
I Mean this is just fact if you watch any one of those videos
hE tOoK mE LiKe ThE sLiGhTlY LoNgEr RoUtE, aNd i ThOuGhT i WaS gOiNg To GeT KiLlEd
Hard to swallow pills
Saying stfhtffffff
(Laughs at truth)
Yes it does, okay?
What am I supposed to say
sHuT.. jUsT bE qUiEt
I need substitute words or something this is ridic..
My god. This is already so accurate you use copyrighted material again
That's the only way to make your videos funny, but that's why I get demonetized. You don't pay me anyway, so just shttf..
Can't even afford your stupid chick Brad 2 to was my favorite Brad all along.
This is honestly the most accurate meme I've ever seen
so I will at least make sure the video doesn't get demonetized
If the video is demonetized, Brad is literally just like I I guess that's how it is
Have I told you about my suka? Yeah merch by the way pretty cool. It means good friend in Swahili
this is my most slav moment of this channel I
I have decided to shut down dramalert as I have recently discovered it is inferior to Pew News
I now hand the news to you PewDiePie. Well this has just been fact all along plus
I'm not the one doing the news you did silly no. It's Gloria Borger
( Pew news theme song )
Ever wonder why he's big doesn't use captcha?
Because he's a ROBOT LIZARD!!!
This is how good memes die because you guys can't figure out
What the what the meme is?
You keep changing them like they have to have no value if you don't treat it like it doesn't have any value
Then it doesn't get any
Respect the memes and you get that respect back
*less than 10 seconds of silence for all the memes we have killed *
That is so cool. I love it Sam Jones art
That is so dope
Some of the world's greatest thinkers
That's right, everybody
Brad 1 and Brad 2 the wise submissions, that's right to get on the wire
You really got a mooch up with Brad 1 and Brad 2 - it's not me, okay
I'm not the one in control of this just like I'm not in control of Bonus meme (Liar)
Ayyyeee
My Russian friend did this art
Did you know you have a big community in Russia?
Well, Russia.. Russian SquadFam :D
It's time to put your wallet where your mouth is, okay? That's really cool art by the way I would really love it
Everyone says that Ninja broke a record by gaining 1 million subscribers in nine days
But they actually forgot about the legend
that gained getting 1 million subscribers in just a few hours. It's okay. Don't worry guys
I'm completely used to my achievements and goals completely getting crushed by everyone else. It's normal
You know I'm a humble man. I don't need to brag about these things
Every day spent on this Subreddit is a privilege (Thanks again)
Oh my god
( Deja vu song )
👏 👏 👏 👏 👏 👏 👏 👏 👏 👏
Yeah, well done! Good job. I'm glad glad you spend a lot of time making that. Nice one, Well done  👏 👏  👏 👏
Now this is an accurate
[coughs]
Oh my god
(Bronchitis confirmed)
Also comes in red by the way, it's pretty cool.
Let's start with the hair
OMG
You know, you gotta go on the television convoys and all that? You gotta get yourself a nice haircut
I dunno what that haircut is called, but I'm next time
I'm going to the barber and I'm showing him a picture of this
That's 😙👌 that's what I want
(You at least got what you asked for. You must consider yourself lucky Pewds)
Ohh.. why? Why did I do this?
Goddammit. I'm a self.. I'm a self-fulfilling prophecy
My drawing of Zucc, his true identity.
Oh.My.God
Lizard Android, Lizard Android if you don't draw him with at least one red eye that goes up, but then I don't care, okay
Don't waste my time with this. Oh my god. Oh my god
I'm so proud of you guys
Is it supposed to be like Iron Man reference?
Yeah, that's funny. This was the top meme by far
Congratulations. Everyone. That's it for this week's of LWIAY
and link merch and a description copy it now while you can it's only available limited availability
Thank you guys so much for all the memes. I mean you're welcome for the memes, and I'll see you guys
next time
*SquadFam out*
aaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa
Stupid Pewds, He scared me. I will have my revenge
Subtitles and comments by Blacklight (If anyone else added please tag yourself too. Anyone not here can be found in description. Thank you guys)